Wow okay that's a lot more people tuning
in for this tie an anticipated oh my
goodness
first of all apologies in advance to my
mods because although just that because
a account this account this high of
people watching probably probably means
there's gonna be a lot of folks here who
are here to express the same sentiments
that they express on my other channel
which was part of the reason I was
hosting this here as opposed to on the
bureau while channel because that one is
now obviously kind of in the crosshairs
at the moment so again apologies to my
mods and also apologies to anyone in the
chat so first let's catch up anyone who
isn't familiar with what what happened
and what I'm even talking about and yes
I am I'm actually in the bath I am
choosing to relax I feel like after the
last 24 hours
I've earned it oh and just let's note
this because I just saw this turn up in
the chat let's not throw harsh insults
either at me or at any of the people I'm
about to talk about
so no personal attacks please even if
they're directed at someone else and you
think that you're doing it to defend me
please don't okay let's let's maintain a
civil behavior through all this as best
we can okay so
Oh in case anyone was scared some people
brought up no buttons actually smash
this during the Sonic review so
yesterday
Blaire white is that tea no I'm not this
is not about spilling tea I'm trying
very hard not to do that
I think Moscato is what it is so Blaire
white who you may or may not have heard
of she is a transgender pundit she is
conservative I don't really want to get
into a bunch of politics about it I
don't think that's an um I don't think
that's a controversial way to
characterize her I feel like that's fair
I hope it is so she put out a video
yesterday that heavily featured one of
my videos from the very wild channel
important question what are you drinking
Moscato so the video that she featured
and she did I will call it a takedown
she described it more of as a deep dive
I don't want to get bogged down scens in
semantics but she basically played clips
of my video to then offer her
disagreeing opinion the video in
question was the one where I talked
about being trans while not having
dysphoria which is a position that she
not only disagrees with feels is harmful
towards transgender people who do
experience dysphoria and actually her
position is that if you don't have
dysphoria then you're not actually trans
now I don't actually want to get into a
discussion of who's right who's wrong
I'm not here to rebut what she said I'm
more interested in just sort of
processing everything that's going on in
the last 24 hours
so then I mean part of the reason I'm
doing this is so I don't have to talk
about it on Tuesday
on the regularly scheduled live stream I
kind of want to cleanse myself I like
literally cleanse myself so the video
featured me in the thumbnail my face and
the thumbnail and as I said it was she
wasn't rude or cruel she did not
directly attack me as a person and but
it was obviously unkind to the position
I was expressing in that video now this
was something that was brought to my
attention by a number of people and a
couple of interesting things happened
now the first thing for me to mention is
that this is not my first rodeo this is
not the first time that a youtuber with
a substantially larger following than me
has decided to do some sort of take down
or rebuttal of something that I've done
and what's interesting about having had
this experience before is I can actually
make a fairly direct comparison so I've
talked before up to this point I never
said the channel that had done the had
done this to me before largely just
because I wasn't trying to start a fight
anywhere it's now been two years
so before I say who it is please again
don't dog pile don't dog pile Blair and
don't dog pile baring who was the one
who did this to me two years ago that
one was in regards to the video the
initial video that I made when Scarlett
Johansson was cast to play a trans man
and that ultimately did pan out she
dropped out a project pretty much
falling apart but anyways he featured me
oh thank you Rachel loving a lot to stay
safe thanks so much
um so he featured not only my video he
also featured Jackson bird because
Jackson
it also made a critical video of that
and he did not dissimilar to Blair and
actually what these sorts of videos tend
to do always which is to take out
specific pieces of the video without the
full context and to either mock or
dispute something along the lines for
the specific bits that they chosen to
highlight that's just kind of a feature
of these kinds of videos so I'm not even
going to necessarily say that either he
or Blair were worse quote-unquote that's
just what these kinds of videos are it's
what they do but here's the thing that
one two years ago which in his case he
did it to a council of geeks video
blended it with a bear a wild video so
with when Baron did it for weeks almost
a month his followers
descended on my channel with harassing
comments and rudeness to me and my
subscribers and other commenters again
for weeks and there were tons of them I
had to I had to come up with whole new
parameters for what would flag comments
so that they would go under Auto review
so that I could you know look at them
before they went they could be seen
public I had to come up with whole new
things because they were finding new
ways to insult and attack me now at the
time that the video was done baring had
about 20 times the subscriber base that
council of geese did so by comparison to
Blair who again chose to target a video
from very wild very wild has fewer
subscribers than council geeks and her
subscribers outnumber mine by a factor
of 75 and despite that
I have had just wrong numbers way fewer
cool comments that I've had to dig
through and get rid of I have had some
I've had I would like to think more than
my share for a 24-hour period but again
because I can compare it to the last
time that this happened to me this has
not been nearly as bad plus off so I
have I have the experience of going
through it before behind me so you know
I'm not green to it anymore now I don't
have any way of knowing this first
certainty but if I were to guess for the
primary reason why I saw much more
direct confrontation from barring
subscribers than I'm currently seeing
from Blair is one down to one simple
thing I drew a very hot by heaven I
could see I'm sweating so not this is a
combination bath and sauna apparently
but the key difference was Behrens video
in the description he included a link to
my video into Jackson's videos that he
was citing which meant that his
followers were only one click away from
getting to me and being able to harass
me
Blair by contrast did not include a link
to my video nor did she tag me on
Instagram or Twitter or anywhere else
where she promoted the video now I have
absolutely no way of knowing whether she
did not tag me as a consideration
because you know I was concerned that I
was gonna get dogpile or if she didn't
do it simply because it would have been
more work to include the links but the
practical upshot is the same either way
it meant that anyone who saw her video
who wanted to
come at me had to do a little bit of
legwork not a lot it would not have been
very hard but it would have been more
effort than just clicking on a link and
one of the Oh Pam Thank You Lexi I have
massive dysphoria but if someone who
faces a lot of gatekeeping I'm appalled
one fellow trans people do it to others
be safe Thank You Lexi oh and also Thank
You halo it's a weird situation for me
because I follow you both decent number
of folks do do you that really am
sweating should I left the door open
have a little priest in here get out now
because cameras going um sorry hold on
give me one second no sorry anyways so
the practical upshot
and because I've long operated on the
presumption that the human animal is is
fundamentally lazy that's not to say no
one ever puts in hard work but the more
work is involved in something the fewer
people are ultimately going to do it
because not enough of them care enough
to put in the extra work
so because Blair did not feature a link
to to my video it meant that people had
to do additional work which most of them
weren't willing to do and as a result
way less direct harassment this time
that having been said there there's some
things about well honestly there's two
main things about the video and this is
not about me
disagreeing with her position because
truth be told I would be more than
willing to have a one-on-one
conversation with her about that and I
say conversation not debate because I'm
not looking to get on a platform and
argue with her I would like to have a
very honest back-and-forth where you
know we try and come to a better
understanding of each other but the so
I'm not about to
her positions I am however going to
point out two things that she did that
I feel were either unfair or sufficient
thought was not put into the impact of
them so either these things were done
consciously which I would find
regrettable or they were done and then
the consequences weren't thought about
which the practical upshot is the same
either way
but that does make a slight difference
in terms of my assessment of the person
who made the video so the first has to
do with the inclusion of my face on the
thumbnail and the name of the video
because the name of the video was I'm
transferring which honestly as far as
video titles go is a perfectly fine
video title I do however take issue with
the fact that she put that in quotes
next to my face which implies that that
was a thing that I said or that it was
at the very least a paraphrasing of
something that I said and it was neither
so that's my first problem my other
problem hat does have to do with the
substance of the video a little bit more
at least in terms of how it was
presented because I was not the only
person she talked about in the same
video she talked about a person who I'm
not going to name but whose name was
visible on the images of text that she
put up that person claimed to be trans
without this for you and made threats
towards her which first off let's be
very clear not okay absolutely not okay
she said she went to the police and I'm
glad she should have no one should be
making bodily harm threats of bodily
harm to anybody for expressing
and an opinion of this nature like that
should be happening so I don't have a
problem with her calling out that
behavior my issue is that while she
never said anything to imply or state
that the person who made the threats and
me were the same person and actually if
you pay attention it's clear that it
isn't there's images of this person that
are clearly not me and like I said the
name is visible there and it's obviously
again clearly not me
but she never makes the distinction of
going okay now I'm going to talk about
another person she just transitions from
talking about threats to talking about
my video which has resulted in at least
one person who came at me very harshly
who did believe that I was the one who
issued those tats so something hold on
your nose look sunburn did a video in
the bath my subscribers would be great
if I did a video in the bathroom I
subscribe would be screaming for the
night Donna I doubt that's the case I've
been a follow yours forever I love you
Doctor Who vids Blairsville AZ and like
she was trying to hit the ten-minute
mark for ad money I mean I mean I don't
I don't follow her stuff so I don't know
how it I don't know if that standard to
what usually does if compared to other
things if there was less work but it I
can't make that call I don't subscribe
to her channel so coming back to this oh
sorry
thank you quick sticks as a gay man I'm
disgusted by so many other gay bi and
trans people throwing the rest of the
lgbtq+ community under the bus for the
sake of acceptance it's it disheartens
me as well but it is it can get
complicated anyways so the other issue
around this whole thing having to do
with the way that it was presented so as
I said she does not clearly indicate
that I was not the person who issued the
threats but if you pay attention is
clear that I wasn't
but even if you know that even if you
watch and you understand that these are
two different people she's talking about
the fact that she goes from talking
about a trans person who does not have
dysphoria who made threats to her - then
critiquing a video by someone who is
talking about being trans without having
this forea that implicitly links violent
behavior to me and what I'm talking
about into anyone who identifies
similarly and I I have a big problem
with that the the fact that there is no
context given for why you would put
these two images together so like if I
ever did a video where I went from
talking about a speech from Hitler to
talking about a and then started
critiquing a video from a conservative
pundit and I didn't give context or a
reason why I just put those things back
to back in the same video that's a
pretty an awful implication I'm not
saying you can't connect the things but
you need to give context as to why
you're doing that and she doesn't she
just goes from here's this one person
who's trans without this or believes
themselves to be trans without dysphoria
I'm trying not to be argumentative of
her point sorry one second I just want
to say love him support sorry this is
going Thank You Tracy
she goes from that person who threatened
her to me who's making a similar stance
but doesn't mention her and and actually
has he never in any social media
platform until today ever talked about
Blair White at all that and and giving
no context as to why she's going from
one to the other and just putting them
back to back that creates very at best
unfair and I would argue dangerous
Association because if you disagree with
my stance that
of having a trans identity without
having dysphoria and you contrast that
or complement it or compare it or
otherwise juxtapose it with someone with
a similar identity who's threatening
violence you're implying a lot about me
that it's not that's not a fair thing to
do you're taking one person with who is
doing a demon lis important thing of
threatening bodily harm and another who
in the process of doing that happens to
express a certain point of view now you
find someone else with that same point
of view who is not expressing threat of
bodily harm to anyone and you're joining
them together you're making a comparison
you are linking them in the minds of
your audience and again I have
absolutely no way of knowing if this was
done with intent or out of carelessness
whether was done with full knowledge of
what was being implied or if she just
felt that because we have similar
identities might as well lump these two
things together and then didn't think it
through what that meant I don't know I
have no way of knowing and I'm not gonna
presume but it does make that link it
makes that connection between me and
someone who threatened her life and
we're outs of a point you're making I
have a big fundamental problem with
anyone who does that whatever your
political point is even if you're making
a point about transgenderism or anything
else that I agree with if you do that I
have a problem with a house so those are
the two things that I felt the need to
specifically take issue
with because I feel like I can address
those things without getting into the
substance of who's right and who's wrong
cuz as I said I would not be opposed and
would even welcome a conversation with
her because the position that she holds
I have a lot of questions about and I
would I would prefer not to have to go
through 150 videos to find the answers
especially you know I'm not being
certain that they're even there like
I've given her position there's a lot of
questions that that brings up for me
things like her stance on non-binary
people non-binary people who experience
dysphoria does she have an issue with
them considering themselves trans even
though they have not transitioned into
the opposing gender from male to female
or female to male but instead have
transition to somewhere in the middle
but they still have dysphoria is she
okay with them identifying his trans I
would be curious to know what
terminology she would be okay with me
identifying us because if her her stance
is that I should not be calling myself
trans and again I have an opposing
viewpoint I'd be happy to discuss that
with her but then what should I pull
myself because I don't think by any
measure I have any business being called
sis
because as I've pointed out I may not
have transitioned into living full-time
as a woman but I have absolutely
transitioned out of identifying and
living as a man that's long behind me at
this point so you know where does that
leave me and the other thing is a fair
number of people from who obviously saw
her video commented thinks the extent of
your gender-fluid you're a transvestite
you're across dress or call yourself
these things and I do call myself gender
fluid I think the argument is that from
my perspective gender fluid is a form of
trans so I don't claim to be you know to
not be gender fluid I think there's just
a disagreement between myself and her as
to whether or not that should be covered
under the overall label of transit again
I'm not trying to have that debate here
but it's very interesting to me to see
comments like that basically boil down
to just call yourself a crossdresser and
everything will be fine
except it won't be and I know that from
experience because I did identify as a
crossdresser for a very long time and if
these people have looked at earlier
videos on that channel they would have
known that but I still got very very
very very hurt pushback from people with
similar views to Blair and what appear
to be views of her audience who would
tell me that I was harming trans people
basically by existing so when she says
you're harming us by identifying as
trans just call yourself the
crossdresser or hip hurt she didn't say
those exact words so I don't mean to put
words in her mouth but when her
subscribers and her followers say
something to that extent my first
thought is but I did I'm gonna find a
crossdresser and I got just as much
harsh pushback from similar sources back
then so the issue doesn't seem to be
what I call myself the issue seems to be
my existence the issue seems to be what
they feel I'm not not what I actually am
sorry game yeah scroll away from me let
me pull that up
I would think trans could be permanent
or temporary trans is just moving from
one to the other again like I
do I do understand the position that she
holds I don't agree with it but I do
understand it and oddly enough some of
the people who came from her channel
didn't seem to agree that trance was a
thing either some of them which was very
strange to me but I'm not gonna keep
this going too much long cuz I am god I
was sweaty mess um but I here's the
funny thing and this is me wanting to
end it on a little bit more of an upbeat
note so her highlighting that video I
had the biggest subscriber bump that I
had in six months and the biggest view
bump that I had in a year and there were
a heartwarmingly high number of comments
on the video saying hey we support you
we love what you do and what really was
hurting to me is the vast majority of
those weren't attacking Blair they were
offering me consolation which is what I
needed because I don't want or need
people to attack another person on my
behalf
actually I would say please don't but
what did help was seeing people leaving
comments saying what you do matters what
you are is valid and that was wonderful
so I wanted to to wrap up on on that
note because as weird as the last 24
hours of bid they could have been much
much much much worse and actually I kind
of expected them to be a lot worse than
they were so
I suppose consider all that silver
lining 600 people I'm pretty sure that
that is a record for a live stream oh my
goodness I wish I kind of wish I had
more to say so I could keep it going but
I've said what I came to say and I want
to thank folks for listening I really
Tracy thank you I really want to thank
my mods for keeping on top of this I I
cannot imagine it was easy tonight with
this many people but thank you thank you
for coming thank you for listening for
those who support me in whatever way you
do whether it is with your money or with
your words I greatly appreciate it and
if you want to push back against what
happened Thank You Raven support for me
is what I would ask for instead of
vitriol against Blair I don't want that
I definitely don't want that done in my
name well thank you Gabe people are
people so why should it be you and I get
along so awfully well said so I am gonna
wrap it up there thank you so much for
tuning in hearing me out and I want you
to remember you are beautiful you are
valid you are loved
you are the council I just run the
meeting thanks so much everybody
have a good night
be safe